[Musique]
récemment, il y avait une femme blanche, il a vu
l'idée des années 50 dans le parc Christian
pourriez-vous acheter exclusivement pour Olivo, elle a
dessiné deux nouveaux ziba dit de potosí tête
[Musique]
Je serais la fée marraine c'est assez
délicat parce que ce genre  d'emblématique en ce
que tout le monde sait ce qu'est une fée
marraine est sa maison tu es comme fini
par un bâton J'ai initialement eu l'
idée qu'elle pourrait ne pas être totalement
efficace très bien mais fondamentalement elle
a un point fabuleux Enis elle est amusée par la
façon dont  difficile qu'il soit ou non de transformer une
citrouille en calèche ou un lézard
en cocher alors qu'elle est au
milieu de cette ruée pour préparer Cendrillon
Davila vous l'a appris helena est tout simplement
merveilleuse et la parfaite très bonne
mère les
gens regardent ça  et pense à ce qui
va se passer ensuite même s'ils
connaissent l'histoire ils ont l'impression de la
regarder pour la première fois
pas d'éclaboussure c'est un hommage
Danny coins
Tippett est le touchant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi